aquí tengo una tabla de datos cuya
primera columna son valores de tiempo
indicándome que después de 75 segundos
un móvil un objeto un cuerpo ha
recorrido 5 metros después de 120
segundos ha recorrido 8 metros y después
de 270 segundos se ha recorrido 20
metros quiero mostrar estos datos en
algún tipo de gráfica y estoy interesado
en saber cuál es la escala que debo de
usar para esta gráfica aquí nos dan
cuatro opciones para la forma más
precisamente para la escala que debo de
utilizar para hacer esa gráfica así por
ejemplo para la opción a tenemos una
escala de 1 para ambos ejes mientras que
para la opción b
tenemos una escala de 50 para el eje de
segundos y una escala de 2 para el eje
de metros y así continúan las demás
opciones lo que te pido que hagas ahora
es una pausa en el vídeo y pienses cuál
de estas opciones cuál de estas escalas
es la más apropiada para graficar los
datos que tenemos aquí
todos los datos son positivos así es que
puedo restringir me a la parte positiva
del eje x y a la parte positiva del eje
y y tomando en cuenta que los segundos
determinar los metros este es la
variable independiente y esta es la
variable dependiente entonces en nuestro
eje horizontal déjame hacerlo con
espacio suficiente para tener varias
gráficas entonces en nuestro eje
horizontal vamos a tener los segundos
mientras que en el eje vertical vamos a
tener los metros y aquí voy a poner
algunas marcas generales 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 deja de poner las más claras
aquí 67 ahora voy a copiar y pegar esto
entonces tengo aquí
y tenemos 2 ahí tenemos una tercera
gráfica y ahí ya tenemos cuatro gráficas
ahora voy a incluir las escalas que
tenemos aquí para que veamos cuál es la
mejor opción empecemos entonces con la
gráfica a digamos que esta es la gráfica
y la escala aquí es de 1 en el eje s 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 y también es de 1 en el eje en
el eje de metro su eje de distancia
debería de decir 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 tratemos
de graficar estos datos después de 75
segundos ha avanzado 5 metros como
puedes ver 75 segundos no aparece en la
escala ni siquiera creo que pudiera
aparecer aquí a la derecha de tu monitor
así es que este dato no aparece aquí
inclusive estos datos estarían más a la
derecha así es que ninguno de los datos
aparecerían con la escala que tiene esta
gráfica sin embargo creo que aquí podría
intentar algo así
aquí podría intentar
algo así podría indicar que me estoy
brincando unos datos esto usualmente se
denota poniendo un hueco ahí pones una
marca como estas para indicar que
brincas de varios datos y como aún
quiero mantener la escala de un segundo
aquí podríamos empezar en 75 segundos
75-76 al cuarto que estoy indicando que
aquí hay un hueco de 0 a 75 segundos 77
ya podríamos obra graficar
75 segundos y 5 metros que estaría
ubicado aquí pero luego 120 segundos
iría también a la derecha en esta
gráfica 8 metros no está incluido en el
eje vertical 270 segundos no está
incluido tampoco en el eje horizontal
como tampoco 20 metros está incluido en
el eje vertical así es que
definitivamente descartamos esta escala
para ambos ejes veamos ahora la gráfica
ve la escala en el eje ese es de 50
esta es la gráfica de la escala de 50
100 150 200 250 y aquí tendríamos 2 4 6
8 10 12 14 veamos entonces cómo
podríamos graficar nuestros puntos el
primer punto 75 segundos 5 metros aquí
tendríamos 50 75 masones por aquí aquí
serían 5 metros
el segundo punto sería 120 segundos y 8
metros 120 segundos y 8 metros más o
menos por aquí lo tenemos el tercer
punto sería 270 segundos aquí tenemos
veamos 50 100 150 200 250 aquí estaría
270 más 11 la mitad y 20 metros que
estaría más o menos por aquí estaría
fuera de la región que hemos puesto para
la gráfica pero siempre podemos ampliar
esta región si extendemos un poco el eje
vertical
vamos a extender el eje vertical para
poder incluir ese punto aquí tenemos 14
6 18 20 por lo que ya pudimos graficar
todos los datos así es que si si me
gusta esta opción b veamos ahora la
opción c
y la voy a hacer en azul esta es la
gráfica ce tenemos la misma escala
horizontal que la gráfica del 50 100 150
200 250 300 y el eje vertical tiene
escala de 10 en 10 10 20 30 vamos a
graficar los puntos vamos a graficar los
puntos en esta gráfica c para empezar
tenemos el punto 75 5 entonces 75 para
los segundos 5 para los metros lo
tenemos ahí lo serían 120 segundos 8
metros 120 segundos hasta 120 mientras
que 8 metros está ahí y finalmente 270
segundos 20 metros 270 lo tenemos aquí
20 metros está aquí y ahí tendríamos
entonces la gráfica de nuestros puntos
estaría en todos los puntos caben pero
por así decirlo se comprimen los valores
de distancia es difícil distinguir entre
5 y 8 metros pero bueno no está mal
esta opción se analicemos ahora
gráfica de analicemos la gráfica de se
me están acabando los colores lo voy a
hacer en este café no no se ve muy bien
no va a ser en blanco no va a ser en
blanco entonces la escala es de 200 para
el eje s 200 400 con eso es suficiente
para nuestros datos y para el egm 2 4 6
6 8 10 12 14 tenemos el punto 75.5 a ver
aquí tenemos 200 la mitad es 100 así es
que 75 estaría más o menos por aquí y 5
para la distancia estaría aquí
luego el punto 120 8 que estaría más o
menos por aquí y finalmente el punto 270
20 270 y 20 que quedaría más o menos por
aquí así es que esta es la gráfica de y
al igual que en la opción c
pudimos graficar todos los datos pero
los datos se ven por así decirlo
comprimidos no se pueden distinguir
entre sí en la gráfica se se comprimen
el eje vertical mientras que la gráfica
de s comprimen en el eje horizontal
concluyendo definitivamente descartamos
la opción a b es muy buena opción pues
se puede distinguir claramente las
diferencias en las distancias en la
gráfica ce las medidas se comprimen para
el eje vertical mientras que en la
gráfica de las medidas se comprimen
mucho para el eje horizontal no uso
completamente el espacio por así decirlo
así es que yo diría que la gráfica de
tiene la mejor escala para los datos que
tenemos aquí déjame corregir este no es
el color que use para ver la gráfica de
es la que presenta la mejor escala para
los datos